Cellular signaling is a complex system
of communication that governs all basic
activities of the cell. There are no cells that
don't do signaling. Bacteria and eukaryotic cells
may do signaling slightly differently. But they
still do have an integrated correlated system
that's responsible for triggering functions of
the cell through a series of discrete steps.
Protein signaling can be dissected into three
basic steps. It starts with the receival of a
signal, then transduction of the signal, and
finally, a response. In the first step in the
process, there's a buildup of a concentration of a
signal or ligand. It occupies the receptors on the
surface of the cell, and in some cases, inside the
cell. Upon binding of the ligand to the receptor,
it may cause the conformational changes
of the receptor and trigger the signal
to be transduced from extracellular to
intracellular, followed by a response.
There are a few characteristics
of all cell signal transduction.
First, is the specificity of the signaling
molecule. The most important thing about
the signal is that the signal, which
binds to a receptor in a cell membrane,
is specific for a particular receptor, and the
different signal won't bind to the same receptor.
This is achieved by high affinity protein-protein
interactions such as hydrogen bonding,
electrostatic interactions, non-covalent
interactions and etc, so that a low concentration
of the signal molecule is efficient for binding
to the receptor to trigger the function.
The next characteristic is amplification.
Very commonly, a cell might have a response
that's just the result of a single
molecule binding a single receptor.
However, if the cell wants a large response, for
example, the cell might want to make a lot of ATP,
or want to replicate the whole genome,
it will need some kind of amplification
where it can turn up the volume of the signal
rapidly. So frequently in signaling pathways,
the cell will go through a cascade of reactions
where the signal might affect an enzyme.
Once the cell make that enzyme active, it might
work on many, many copies of another enzyme.
And then each of those may work on even more
copies. At some point, a single signaling
molecule can result in the cascade of a reaction,
similar to a waterfall coming from just a single
molecule of water. The cell will get a large
increase in signal as a result of amplification.
The next feature or characteristic
of signaling is feedback.
Once enough response is achieved, the
cell needs to stop the signaling process.
Negative feedback loop provides a mechanism
to slow down some of those steps that are
involved in amplification, so that the pathway
is turned on for a prescribed amount of time.
Finally, the other component of a signaling
network is integration. If we look at a signaling
pathway, all these signaling steps are not single.
For example, in the signal transduction that
regulate apoptosis and cell proliferation,
there might be just a single signal that is
being received, but other components may have
crosstalk within one pathway. This can set
off the different component in the pathway either
amplifying or turning down a particular signaling.
Similar to an electrical circuit, the signal can
trigger not just a single pathway, but a network
of pathway interacts and communicate with each
other, to amplify signals or turn down signals.
Hence, integration is an important part of
signaling, because you will often be dealing
with the integrated function of a number
of pathways to get a particular response.
And that actually ends up being one of the
situations where sometimes a particular enzyme
may look like a perfect target for a therapeutic
agent. But if you don't take into account the
integration steps, instead of dealing with
a single pathway, you may be dealing with
crosstalk with a lot of other pathways. What’s
more important is that, in a cell, there is always
compensation from other pathways which might
nullify the therapeutics response that you wanted.
There are many types of signaling molecules.
They may be small molecules, for example, an
amino acid or a phospholipid. Alternatively, they
may be proteins like hormone or cytokine. They may
be carbohydrates. They might take different
forms in terms of their molecular structure.
But we tend to describe signals by where they come
from. An autocrine signal is a signal that may
come from a cell, but it is signaling to itself.
It may produce a component that is released
through a secretory pathway and stays in the
vicinity of the cell. It is like a self-signaling.
Paracrine signaling normally occur where the
signaling molecule is produced by a neighboring
cell. Endocrine is usually produced by cells from
a distance, such as from other tissues or organs,
and coming through the circulatory system. And
finally, juxtacrine is the only one that is a
little odd. The signaling is actually coming
from direct physical contact between 2 cells.
So, it is not self-signaling within a cell. It
is also not something secreted by another a cell.
It is a signal that triggered
through physical contact.